Pilar on the page it's been around since
yeah on the page has been around since
2001 I have a writer studio in Los
Angeles where I teach live classes and I
teach them on first draft rewrite pitch
TV some story analysis you know just
whatever I think that a writer needs in
the moment and also I have a podcast
called on the page we've been doing it
for I don't know seven or eight years
weekly podcasts with writers and
producers anybody who can talk script
and how did you get into doing this
how did I get into doing this it's kind
of a sideways move a friend had asked me
to read a script for her for a company
she was working at I found out you could
get paid for doing that huh and I ended
up sending my samples to Amblin
entertainment at the time which was
Steven Spielberg's company and I got
hired as a reader and I kind of learned
on the job reading not only for Amblin
but also DreamWorks when they became
DreamWorks and a number of other
companies and then I ended up teaching
based on what I was learning from
reading scripts and seeing how people
were responding to them what was working
and what wasn't working I tried to
translate those into tools and those
classes became popular became a book
stuff like that well we're here at story
Expo 2015 and we're getting you in
between classes and so forgive me if I'm
a little rushed here I just wanted to
find your take on this right now I'm
reading a Joyce Carol Oates book the
faith of a writer which is sort of about
her life and she talks about the writers
sort of isolation and some of the things
that are a little bit darker that some
of these books don't always cover one of
the things she says is the artist is
born
damned and struggles through his or her
life to achieve an ever elusive
Redemption by way of their art Wow Wow
lot designer
I know product that the artist is born
damned is very interesting to me because
I think that some people can feel that
they've been dammed by creativity that
there is this need to express something
and they are sort of in a personal jail
until they can get it out
and I think that that might be what
she's going for there is to talk about
this fact that it's not that an artist
creates because they want to make money
they create because they have to and and
and as far as that personal Redemption I
think it's more that idea of sort of a
personal release but I think she's
certainly on to something everybody's a
little dammed and they're better people
for it
trysting I like that should a
screenwriter have a plan B should a
screenwriter have a plan B huh I guess
look on a practical level I guess every
artist should have a way that they can
make money but not as the that that plan
that says well I'm going to give up
eventually and then I should do this I
think there it's fine to have a job that
you love that supports the art that you
love and I think what you'll find too is
that they often go hand in hand you know
you can bring your writing to a day job
and you can bring the experiences from
your life and day job and family into
your writing so it these things don't
have to compete what makes a good story
for me I'm always saying it's action
plus emotion because the kind of
storytelling that I teach is scripted
story storytelling so we have to see it
and we have to feel it action begets
emotion which begets more action so to
me it's the marriage of these two things
where do you see writers struggling the
most when they come into your classes
what are some of the things they share
with you where they struggle the most is
I think probably this need to to follow
rules and get it right and there are no
real rules and there is no one way to
get it right so I'm always trying to get
them just to express their intention for
the story on pages as best they can if
they've met that intention that's right
you know those are their rules so I
think that's that's that's where I see
artists struggling is oh you know it's
got to be perfect no it doesn't it just
has to be what you want
like that what can a screenwriter do to
get better at their craft is that is
that basically it to just kind of
express that underlying emotion without
trying to be so perfect in explaining a
certain story that if they were a little
more free with it
yeah I do think that there are you on
the other hand certain tools and
techniques that they can use for for
paring down their work for focusing
their work for making sure that they're
meeting their intentions by picking the
words that best express that by placing
the words where they need to by really
focusing their scenes so that their
scenes tell a story so it's not a
question of oh just be free okay it is a
question of really looking at your art
and making sure that you are telling the
story as best you can with those
intentions in mind I say don't meet make
it perfect because it doesn't have to be
but you do have to spend some time
focusing does it make sense it does it
does is there a point that a writer
should give up on a screenplay is there
a point that a writer should give up on
a screenplay no I you know no I don't
think so because I think you all heard
those stories of I am then I put in in
Shore and then six years later somebody
wanted this or a world event happened
and it was just right so you might put
it aside for the moment because it's not
getting the traction you want it's it's
it's or you yourself have tired of it
and you want to move on to something
else go ahead put it in the drawer but
don't get rid of it that is a piece of
art that will find its way eventually do
you believe a screenwriter should write
their first draft as quickly as possible
just kind of regurgitate it out of
themselves and then revise from there oh
you're talking about the vomit draft
aren't you all right we have such nice
expressions for it yes I do and I urge
my students not to look back that's
where the perfection starts to come in
and they stopped up their writing
process and they have these beautiful
four stacks and then they never go any
further so yes by all means right to the
end and then you can go back in and you
can start honing it and chiseling away
at it or fattening it up make it better
but right to the end so if they plan to
do a 90 page script don't don't stop in
the middle and make sure that it's okay
they've got to just get it all out right
right barrel forward I think I think so
many people make the mistake of going
back and rereading what they wrote the
day before polishing that up and only
moving this much further we don't have
enough time you know we only set so much
writing time in the day you've got to
make as much use of that as you can
press forward is there a timeframe for
writing this first script I think that
time frame is is personal it really
depends on where you fit it in your life
you know I've made my whole philosophy
of teaching is writing in ten minute
increments because of being a busy
person myself and knowing that my
writers are busy so I do believe that
whatever time you have you can make the
best use of it as long as your focus
does the screenplay begin with the word
fade in does it doesn't begin with the
word faded and do you mean like should
you have fade in or not have a baby well
does writing begin with the word fade in
or could someone actually begin part of
it in the middle I have an idea for a
crux of what I want to happen but I
don't have the book ending I don't have
the the finish part I don't have the
beginning yeah I think you can jump
around sure if if you have certain
scenes inside of you that you see
visually that are sort of the tent poles
for the story
by all means write those down and then
write what works up to it and what
Springs off of them but if you get to a
certain place where you're only writing
what you love you're being a little
undisciplined you know at that point you
have to go alright I have to start
writing the scenes that I don't know or
don't love as well then start from the
beginning and start moving toward those
key scenes that you've already written
do you think a lot of writers are
undisciplined it seems like writers of
any of all the arts it seems like
writers are the most sort of discipline
the most heart of themselves the most
sort of reined in yeah a fallacy I don't
find that they're undisciplined but I do
think that we all have little tricks
that we play where we write only things
that we love you know or or that we're
good at you know I've watched a lot of
writers that will write scene after
scene and I'm like yeah I know you can
do this okay where's that scene that's
really hard for you write that so it's
not a question of not being disciplined
so much as you know not wanting to be
taken to task for not not being
wonderful right away what for time
wasting with writers aside from surfing
the internet and quote research what do
you see as some of the stumbling blocks
to time management well I think you just
named two two of them you know surfing
the internet and research right research
is the most creative form of
procrastination where somebody goes no
wait I have to stop I really have to
look that up my my usual advice is no
write what you want and then find the
research that supports that story point
instead of the other way around
but yeah I think that that is the the
place that we all tend to convince
ourselves that we're actually working
and we're not we're surfing the
screenwriters that you know who have
sold screenplays how much of that work
is better than some of those who've just
put it in a drawer they finished it
they've done ten drafts but they're just
not willing to like either take what
they need to do to go out and pitch it
or no one's really looked at it and said
this is the one well you know you're
hitting on on both things that sell so
one is you talked about pitching right
and and there are some people I've seen
who do very well in their careers not
necessarily just sell something so much
as get a career off of the script that
they wrote and I've seen
and and it's one breed of writer that
can just make connections with people
you know convince them first to read the
thing which is hard to do there's that
kind of writer that does very well but
then there's this other kind of writer
that does very well because you have to
pass the script along they have written
something with such a specific voice and
commitment to the characters or an idea
or to a tone that it makes everybody
want to pass the script along so it's
those two things either being really
good at sort of getting your stuff out
there and getting it in front of the
right eyes or being exceptional on the
page one of those two things will get
you the career that you want charisma
versus craft or no it's not just
charisma the first the person who has
charisma and craft that's the person and
I've seen a couple of those and that's a
guaranteed success the people who do
well can have just one charisma or craft
but it would be nice if they had they
had all of them best questions a
screenwriter can ask themselves to
develop a better story right up front is
what is the story what is the movie
story or what is the TV story that's
where the logline comes in that
everybody is so happy to talk about but
it really is a one sentence expression
of your intention if you can't get that
down you might want to go back in and
really re-examine you know is there
something to write here so first of all
ask yourself what is that one sentence
expression once you have that then you
want to ask yourself you know well what
turns you on about that idea okay
based on what excites you about that
idea now ask well what are the scenes
that express that excitement you know
that really really show those beats that
are that you have to show on screen you
know and then keep working backwards
from there okay who are the people that
populate that scene what do they say so
if you start big picture and then you
keep sort of breaking it down to the
things that excite you the people in it
they say I think I think those are the
questions to ask you as you're writing
how should a screenwriter spend their
time let's say for 10 hours that they
dedicate to their career how many of
those 10 hours should be developing an
idea actually writing the screenplay
watching movies which again could go
into research networking reading etc I
think we've spent our life watching and
that we should continue to do so but
that's not really homework it's just
what we do and what we love and now we
don't have to feel guilty about it you
know great okay terrific
so you're doing that anyway as far as
networking goes it is the the question
of keeping your eyes open shaking hands
making friends capitalizing on
relationships that that's also that can
also happen at the same time this is all
sort of multi-platform stuff that you're
doing anyway so when it comes to the
real time spent for writing right you
know you can't really count any of those
things as well I was writing because I
was watching TV and I was making a
friend you got right is that what Seth
Godin II calls the work do the work that
scares us it's always that sounds sounds
right to me right what is the work that
you see scare most people that come into
your classes that you know I think the
work that scares people it depends but
often I see it in sort of the rewrite
process where you have spit out that
first draft where you have written the
scenes that you love and then there's
this you know a problem area that you
have to tackle and first of all figuring
out how to fix it that's that's hard but
even when you know how to fix it
sometimes it's not what you want to do
and it's but you have to that is the
place where it's hardest I think but
once you get past through past past that
through that I think that it's probably
the most rewarding because you really
did the hard work you know just focusing
back on Joyce Carol Oates book the faith
of a writer she has a chapter on failure
I think she touches briefly that a lot
of artists are attracted to failure
hmm do do you have an opinion on that I
don't know I'm not really good at you
know figuring out the psyche of artists
when you're in my class you know I'm
always like leave the drama on the page
you know I want to hear about it let's
get writing you know that's sort of how
how I work and I always feel like sort
of that the writing pushes through the
issues or you can take those issues and
give them to a character this can be
really cathartic for you but as far as
people being attracted to failure maybe
one kind of writer is I don't know if
all writers are I think some people are
just attracted to storytelling when it
comes to selling a screenplay what are
some of the mistakes that you see a lot
of screenwriters make the mistakes would
be desperation insistence you know where
it's you know no you have to read this
minds the only story and you know the
more persistent and desperate you are
the more people back off
I mean think of it if you were dating
you know no you have to go out with me
and this is why you know that's charming
right so so it's when I see people do
that immediately you know they just they
just sort of ruined it the people that
let allow the breathing room in the
relationship and let the words make
somebody come to them that's where you
know deals happen sails happen but again
remember this is mainly about getting
your career going this might be where
you're hired you're not always going to
sell a screenplay that screenplay is
going to sell you well it sounds like
that's where charisma it comes back into
play so how does that work and I'm sure
in LA it's slightly different than in
other parts of the country but how do
people develop that charisma where
they're not too pushy but at the same
time not too meek you know I may have
expressed a wrong with talking about
charisma I was talking about with the
people who make it I see like some some
writers are very good about getting
their stuff out in the world that still
has to be a good product that they're
getting out
some people are just very good at the
page but they still have to be decent
enough in a room that they don't scare
people off it really is a mixture of
both those things but the kind of
charisma we're talking about doesn't
have to be like you know big bold shiny
charisma we're just talking about sort
of an authentic connection I know that
on Thyssen who has a story that they
want to tell who you know it's it's
there and it's the the possibilities of
it are exciting and that the writer has
made those possibilities evident to the
listener like this is what I'm trying to
get out there isn't that interesting oh
yeah that's interesting to me too okay
I'll read it I heard a phrase used the
other day a walking hidden agenda and I
think that sometimes that's when we're
trying to push our stuff out there we
can come across like that we don't mean
to it's just we're very excited about
something so I think that's a very
negative sort of term but it's actually
very like a lot of people shy away from
it in LA because everybody does have
something here they're pitching
maybe something hidden agenda but how
can someone sort of like be excited
about it but not be too aggressive and
if they're working a room with some
passion passion okay good think of
instead of like I have a need it's I
have a passion oh you know and I think
that that would that would work
excellent a walking hidden agenda that
sounds like a really good character
description for like like a an
antagonist oh she's just a walking
hidden agenda about that yeah I know
when I heard it I just lit up because
like wow developing a character we keep
hearing about that there's classes on
that what does this mean and how can
someone develop a character whether it's
someone that's a walking in agenda or
yeah well developing a character I've
got a couple of tools that I use in
class one of them has to do with
developing a skill okay when you watch a
character actually develop a skill
whether it's a physical skill of
fighting or whether it's an emotional
skill of learning how to connect with
somebody you're watching that character
develop and you're watching it
an experience is happening in front of
us a scene is happening an event is
happening we can see the development so
that's one way to develop a character
what skill physically or emotionally are
they developing another way to develop a
character is to think what are their
ongoing patterns or rules that we always
see them do and then do they break that
rule when they break that rule where
they shy away from their pattern they're
developing